THE PRESIDENT: Hello, Maryland!
(Applause.)
Hello, PGCC!
It's good to be back in PG County.
(Applause.)
Give it up for one of the hardest-working,
most effective governors in the country, Governor
Martin O'Malley.
(Applause.)
Well, it is great to be with all of you here
today --
AUDIENCE MEMBER: I love you!
THE PRESIDENT: I love you back.
It's wonderful being here.
(Applause.)
We also have a few folks who work so hard
on behalf of the people of Maryland every
single day: Senator Ben Cardin is here.
(Applause.)
Congressman Steny Hoyer is here.
And Congresswoman Donna Edwards is here.
(Applause.)
And all of you are here.
Sometimes you just need to escape Beltway
politics for a little bit -- even if you're
just a mile or two outside the Beltway.
Now, I know that a lot of you have seen some
of the antics going on in Congress right now.
(Laughter.)
So I wanted to take a little bit of time today
to speak with you -- the people who send us
to serve -- about something that is critical
to our families, critical to our businesses,
critical to our economy.
And that is the reforms that we are making
to our health care system.
There's been a lot of things said, a lot of
misinformation, a lot of confusion.
But there are few things more fundamental
to the economic security of the middle class
and everybody who's trying to get into the
middle class than health care.
For a long time, America was the only advanced
economy in the world where health care was
not a right, but a privilege.
We spent more, we got less.
We left tens of millions of Americans without
the security of health insurance.
By the time the financial crisis hit, most
folks' premiums had more than doubled in about
a decade.
About one in 10 Americans who got their health
care through their employer lost that coverage.
So the health care system was not working.
And the rising costs of health care burdened
businesses and became the biggest driver of
our long-term deficits.
But this has always been about more than just
statistics.
Everywhere I went as I ran for President back
in 2007, 2008, everyplace I've gone as President,
I would hear stories from folks just like
you of insurers that denied a child coverage
because he had a preexisting condition like
asthma; of cancer survivors that had to choose
between their home or their health care; of
small businesses who wanted to do the right
thing by their employees but had seen their
insurance premiums go up so high that they
just couldn't do it anymore.
And these stories were personal for me, because
I remember my mother worrying about how she
was going to deal with her finances when she
got very sick.
I remember the fear Michelle and I felt when
Sasha was a few months old and she got meningitis.
And we raced to the hospital and they had
to give her a spinal tap.
And we didn't know what was wrong and we were
terrified, never felt so scared or helpless
in all of my life.
But we were fortunate enough to have good
health insurance.
And I remember looking around that emergency
room and thinking -- what about the parents
who aren't that lucky?
What about the parents who get hit with a
bill of $20,000 or $30,000 and they've got
no idea how to pay for it?
What about those parents whose kids have a
chronic illness like asthma and have to keep
on going back to the emergency room because
they don't have a regular doctor, and the
bills never stop coming?
Who is going to stand up for them?
In the wealthiest nation on Earth, no one
should go broke just because they get sick.
(Applause.)
In the United States of America, health care
is not a privilege for the fortunate few -- it
is a right.
And I knew that if we didn't do something
about our unfair and inefficient health care
system, it would keep driving up our deficits,
it would keep burdening our businesses, it
would keep hurting our families, and it would
keep holding back economic growth.
That's why we took on a broken health care
system.
That's why, with the help of folks like Steny
and Ben and Donna, we got it through Congress.
That's why we've been implementing it.
That's why we are going to see it through.
The Affordable Care Act is here.
(Applause.)
I don't have to tell you it was a challenge
to get it done.
(Laughter.)
A lot of special interests who liked the system
just the way it was fought us tooth and nail.
Then Republicans decided it was good politics
to fight it, even though the plan we proposed
drew on a lot of Republican ideas.
But despite all the obstacles, the Affordable
Care Act passed both houses of Congress.
I signed it into law.
(Applause.)
The Supreme Court ruled it constitutional.
Republicans in Congress have now voted more
than 40 times to undermine or repeal it.
Their candidate for president ran on a platform
to repeal it.
And at every step, they've been unsuccessful.
(Applause.)
Now, five days from now -- five days from
now -- on October 1st, millions of Americans
who don't have health insurance because they've
been priced out of the market or because they've
been denied access because of a preexisting
condition, they will finally be able to buy
quality, affordable health insurance.
(Applause.)
In five days.
Preexisting conditions, whether it's back
pain or allergies that were sticking you with
sky-high premiums, those no longer will prevent
you from getting affordable coverage that
you need.
That's going to happen in five days.
Now, of course, the closer we've gotten to
this date, the more irresponsible folks who
are opposed to this law have become.
Some of the same Republicans who warned three
years ago that this law would be "Armageddon"
-- that's what they said -- "Armageddon" -- now
they're threatening steps that actually would
badly hurt our entire economy -- not because
of the Affordable Care Act but because of
what they're threatening to do.
Some have threatened a government shutdown
if they can't shut down this law.
Others have actually threatened an economic
shutdown by refusing to pay America's bills
if they can't delay the law.
AUDIENCE: Booo --
THE PRESIDENT: That's not going to happen
as long as I'm President.
(Applause.)
The Affordable Care Act is here to stay.
And so today, I want to speak plainly, clearly,
honestly, about what it means for you and
for the people you care about.
Now, let's start with the fact that even before
the Affordable Care Act fully takes effect,
about 85 percent of Americans already have
health insurance --- either through their
job, or through Medicare, or through the individual
market.
So if you're one of these folks, it's reasonable
that you might worry whether health care reform
is going to create changes that are a problem
for you -- especially when you're bombarded
with all sorts of fear-mongering.
So the first thing you need to know is this:
If you already have health care, you don't
have to do anything.
In fact, for the past few years, since I signed
the Affordable Care Act, a lot of you have
been enjoying new benefits and protections
that you didn't before even if you didn't
know they were coming from Obamacare.
(Applause.)
Let me just give you a few examples.
Because of the Affordable Care Act, more than
100 million Americans have gotten free preventive
care like mammograms and contraceptive care
with no copays.
(Applause.)
Because of the Affordable Care Act, 3 million
young adults under age 26 have gained coverage
by staying on their parents' plan.
(Applause.)
Because of the Affordable Care Act, millions
of seniors on Medicare have saved hundreds
of dollars on their prescription medicine.
They've been getting their prescription drugs
cheaper.
(Applause.)
Because of the Affordable Care Act, just this
year, 8.5 million families actually got an
average of $100 back from their insurance
companies because the insurance companies
spent too much on things like overhead, and
not enough on actual Medicare -- medical care.
(Applause.)
Because of the Affordable Care Act, insurance
companies can no longer put lifetime limits
on the care your family needs, or discriminate
against children with preexisting conditions.
And starting on January 1st, they won't be
able to charge women more for their insurance
just because they're women.
(Applause.)
That's a good thing.
So tens of millions of Americans are already
better off because of the benefits and protections
provided by the Affordable Care Act.
Like I said, they may not know why that rebate
check came in the mail.
(Laughter.)
They may not notice that they're not having
to copay for some preventive care that they
received.
But they're getting those benefits.
That's already happening.
That's already in place today.
It's been going on for several years.
Those are the benefits of Obamacare -- the
law that Republicans want to repeal.
Although it's interesting -- when you ask
Republicans whether they'd repeal the benefits
I just mentioned, when you say to them, well,
do you think it's the right thing to do to
let young people stay on their parents' plans
so they can keep insurance, or do you want
to prevent seniors from getting more discounts
on their prescription drugs, then they'll
say, no, no, no, we like those.
Those things are okay.
(Laughter.)
So they don't like Obamacare in theory, but
some of the component parts, at least those
that poll well, they don't mind.
But that's already in place.
Now, here's the second thing you need to know.
If you're one of over 40 million Americans
who don't have health insurance --- including
hundreds of thousands of folks right here
in Maryland --- starting on Tuesday, five
days from now, you'll finally have the same
chance to buy quality, affordable health care
as everybody else.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Thanks, Mr. President!
(Applause.)
THE PRESIDENT: And I want to break this down
for you.
I want you to know exactly how it works.
The major reason why people don't have health
insurance is either they don't have a job,
or they do have a job but their employer doesn't
offer health insurance, or they're self-employed.
If you've ever tried to buy health insurance
on your own, you know it is really, really
expensive.
AUDIENCE: Yes!
THE PRESIDENT: It's even worse if you have
a preexisting condition --- and up to half
of all Americans have a preexisting condition.
See, the reason it's really expensive if you're
buying it on your own is because you're not
part of a big group, you're not part of a
group plan.
And what groups do is they spread risk between
sick and healthy people, between older and
younger people.
And groups -- because insurance companies
want the business of groups -- that's a lot
of customers -- they'll negotiate a better
deal with a group than they will with an individual.
So if you're on your own, you're out there
trying to negotiate with an insurance company,
they're looking and they're saying, well,
you take it or leave it, I'm going to charge
you a whole lot of money.
And if you've got a preexisting condition,
they'll say, we don't even want to insure
you because we think you might get sick later
on and we don't really want to pay, we just
want to take in premiums.
So if you're not part of a group, you're either
uninsurable, or you need to spend a small
fortune on insurance that oftentimes is not
very good.
That's what's happening right now.
The Affordable Care Act was designed to solve
that problem.
And here's how we do it.
Starting on Tuesday, every American can visit
HealthCare.gov to find out what's called the
insurance marketplace for your state.
Here in Maryland, I actually think it's called
MarylandHealthConnection.gov.
(Applause.)
But if you go to HealthCare.gov, you can look
and they'll tell you where to go.
They'll link to your state.
Now, this is real simple.
It's a website where you can compare and purchase
affordable health insurance plans, side-by-side,
the same way you shop for a plane ticket on
Kayak -- (laughter) -- same way you shop for
a TV on Amazon.
You just go on and you start looking, and
here are all the options.
It's buying insurance on the private market,
but because now you're part of a big group
plan -- everybody in Maryland is all logging
in and taking a look at the prices -- you've
got new choices.
Now you've got new competition, because insurers
want your business.
And that means you will have cheaper prices.
(Applause.)
So you enter in some basic information about
yourself, what level of coverage you're looking
for.
After that, you'll be presented with a list
of quality, affordable plans that are available
in your area.
It will say clearly what each plan covers,
what each plan costs.
The price will be right there.
It will be fully transparent.
Before this law, only a handful of states
required insurance companies to offer you
instant price quotes, but because of this
law, insurers in all 50 states will have to
offer you instant price quotes.
And so if you've ever tried to buy insurance
on your own, I promise you this is a lot easier.
It's like booking a hotel or a plane ticket.
And here's another thing about these new plans.
If you're one of those folks who has a preexisting
condition, these plans have to offer you coverage.
They can't use your medical history to charge
you more than anybody else.
If you couldn't afford coverage for your child
because he had asthma, he's covered.
If you couldn't afford coverage because you
were told heartburn was a preexisting condition,
you're covered.
(Laughter.)
If you're one of the 45 million Americans
with a mental illness, you are covered.
If you're a young adult or entrepreneur striking
out on your own, you're covered.
(Applause.)
If you're a young couple who previously had
insurance that didn't include maternity benefits
and now suddenly you need some maternity benefits,
you're covered.
(Applause.)
If you lose your job and your health care
with it, you're covered.
(Applause.)
So all those things that would deny you coverage
in the past, that were the cruelties of a
broken health care system, on January 1st,
when these plans take effect --
AUDIENCE MEMBER: October 1st.
THE PRESIDENT: No, no, no, no -- hold on.
(Laughter.)
Hold on.
I know what I'm talking about.
You sign up starting on Tuesday.
(Laughter.)
The plan will take effect on January 1st.
And when these plans take effect, all those
things change forever.
Now, what about choice and cost?
In states where the federal government helps
run these marketplaces, the average American
will have more than 50 different plans to
choose from, with different levels of coverage.
And because insurance companies are competing
against one another for your business, a lot
of Americans will pay significantly less for
their insurance than they do now.
Premiums are going to be different in different
parts of the country, depending on how much
coverage you buy.
But 95 percent of uninsured Americans will
see their premiums cost less than was expected.
And many families, including more than two-thirds
of all young adults who buy health care through
these online marketplaces, are also going
to be eligible for tax credits that bring
down the cost down even further.
(Applause.)
So let me be specific.
Right here in Maryland, average 25-year-old
-- have we got any 25-year-olds here?
(Applause.)
All right, so we've got a few.
Some of you raised your hand -- I'm not sure
you're -- (laughter.)
Here in Maryland, average 25-year-old making
$25,000 a year could end up getting covered
for as little as $80 a month -- $80 a month.
(Applause.)
Here in Maryland, a family of four making
$60,000 a year could get covered for as little
as $164 a month.
It's the same story across the country.
In Texas, average 27-year-old making $25,000
could get covered for as little as $83 a month.
In Florida, a family of four making $50,000
could get covered for as little as $104 a
month.
And keep in mind the government didn't set
these prices.
The insurance companies -- they proposed these
prices because they want to get in with these
big groups, with all these new customers.
The insurance companies are saying these marketplaces,
this law, will work.
They're putting money on the line because
they think it will work.
Competition, choice, transparency -- all these
things are keeping costs down.
Knowing you can offer your family the security
of health care -- that's priceless.
Now you can do it for the cost of your cable
bill.
Probably less than your cellphone bill.
(Laughter and applause.)
Think about that.
Good health insurance for the price of your
cellphone bill, or less.
And let's say you're a young woman, you just
turned -- I'm interested in this, because
I got two daughters, right?
Let's say you just turned 26.
Let's say you can't stay on your parents'
plan anymore.
If you buy health care through the marketplace,
your plan has to cover free checkups, flu
shots, contraceptive care.
So you might end up getting more health care
each month than you're paying for the premiums.
All told, nearly 6 in 10 Americans without
health insurance today will be able to get
covered for $100 or less.
It would actually be 8 in 10 if every governor
were working as hard as Governor O'Malley
to make the Affordable Care Act work for their
citizens.
(Applause.)
Unfortunately, we've still got a few Republican
governors who are so opposed to the very idea
of the law -- or at least they're doing it
for politics -- that they haven't lifted a
finger to help cover more people.
Some of them have actually tried to harm the
law before it takes effect.
But a lot of Republican governors are putting
politics aside and doing the right thing.
(Applause.)
And they deserve congratulations for that.
It wasn't easy for them.
But you've got conservative governors in Ohio,
in Michigan, in Pennsylvania and Arizona -- about
eight Republican governors in all, they've
decided to expand Medicaid through the Affordable
Care Act to cover more people in their states.
And millions of Americans without insurance
will get coverage through these programs.
So that's what the Affordable Care Act is.
That's what all the fuss is about.
We're giving more benefits and protections
for folks who already have health insurance,
and we created a new market -- basically a
big group plan -- for folks without health
insurance so that they get a better deal,
and then we're providing tax credits to help
folks afford it.
You would think that would not be so controversial.
(Laughter.)
You would think people would say, okay, let's
go ahead and let's do this so everybody has
health insurance coverage.
The result is more choice, more competition,
real health care security.
And one question people ask: How is it possible
to do all this and keep costs down?
Well, part of what we did was build into the
law all sorts of measures to assure that the
growth of health care costs would start slowing
down.
And it has.
See, under the old system, doctors and hospitals,
they were rewarded not for the quality of
care, but for the quantity of care.
They'd get paid for the number of procedures
they did instead of whether they were working
or not.
Now, there are penalties for hospitals with
high readmission rates.
And last year, surprisingly enough, for the
first time ever, hospital readmission rates
for Medicare patients actually fell.
(Applause.)
Right?
That means fewer taxpayer dollars go to providers
that don't serve their patients well.
Over the past five years, we've more than
doubled the adoption of electronic health
records for physicians.
So that means they can track what's going
on better and make fewer mistakes.
New technology startup companies are coming
up with new inventions to monitor patient
health, prevent infections.
There's innovation going on all across the
country.
As a consequence, today, Medicare costs per
enrollee are rising at the slowest rate in
years.
Employer-based health care costs are growing
at about one-third the rate of a decade ago.
All told, since I signed the Affordable Care
Act into law, we have seen the slowest growth
in health care costs on record.
(Applause.)
So let's think about this.
If you got health insurance, you're getting
better protections, better benefits.
If you don't have health insurance, you're
now getting to be part of a group plan.
And health care costs overall are rising much
more slowly than they did before we signed
the law.
So far, so good.
So what's all the fuss about?
What is it that everybody -- what is that
these Republicans are just so mad about?
AUDIENCE: Booo --
THE PRESIDENT: No, no, no, look, I want to
be honest.
There are parts of the bill that some folks
don't like.
To help pay for the program, the wealthiest
Americans --- families who make more than
$250,000 a year --- will have to pay a little
bit more.
Extremely costly health insurance plans will
no longer qualify for unlimited tax breaks.
And most people who can afford health insurance
now have to take responsibility to buy health
insurance, or pay a penalty.
(Applause.)
Right?
Now, the reason we do that is, when uninsured
people who can afford to get health insurance
don't, and then they get sick or they get
hit by a car, and they show up at the emergency
room, who do you think pays for that?
AUDIENCE: We do.
THE PRESIDENT: You do, in the form of higher
premiums.
Because the hospitals, they've got to get
their money back somehow.
So if they're treating somebody who doesn't
have health insurance, they jack up premiums
for everybody who does have health insurance.
It's like a hidden tax of $1,000 per family
every year who has got health insurance.
So we're saying that's not fair.
If you can afford to get health insurance,
don't dump the costs on us.
The law also requires employers with more
than 50 employees to either provide health
insurance for your workers or pay a penalty.
Now, some folks say, well, that's not fair.
But if you are an employer, you can afford
to provide health insurance, you don't, your
employees get sick, they go to the emergency
room or they end up on Medicaid because you're
not doing what you're doing -- you should
be doing -- why is it everybody else should
be bearing those costs?
Now, there are some folks who disagree with
me on this.
They say that violates people's liberty, telling
them they've got to get health insurance.
Well, I disagree.
So did Congress when it passed this bill into
law.
It is unfair for folks to game the system
and make the rest of us pay for it.
(Applause.)
It's unfair for responsible employers who
are doing the right thing, giving their employees
health insurance, to get undercut by some
operator that's not providing health insurance
for their employees.
That puts the employer who's doing the right
thing at a disadvantage, right?
So this idea that you've got responsibilities
-- everybody -- that's what Massachusetts
did when they passed their health care plan
a few years ago.
And, by the way, today, in Massachusetts,
almost everybody is covered and the system
works pretty well.
(Applause.)
All right, let me just wrap up by saying this:
Like any law, like any big product launch,
there are going to be some glitches as this
thing unfolds.
Folks in different parts of the country will
have different experiences.
It's going to be smoother in places like Maryland
where governors are working to implement it
rather than fight it.
(Applause.)
But somewhere around the country, there's
going to be a computer glitch and the website's
not working quite the way it's supposed to,
or something happens where there's some error
made somewhere -- that will happen.
That happens whenever you roll out a new program.
And I guarantee you, the opponents of the
law, they'll have their cameras ready to document
anything that doesn't go completely right,
and they'll send it to the news folks and
they'll say, look at this, this thing is not
working.
But most of the stories you'll hear about
how Obamacare just can't work is just not
based on facts.
Every time they have predicted something not
working, it's worked.
(Applause.)
I mean, they said that these rates would come
in real high and everybody's premiums would
be sky high.
And it turns out, lo and behold, actually,
the prices came in lower than we expected
-- lower than I predicted.
That's how well competition and choice work.
(Applause.)
They said this would be a disaster in terms
of jobs.
There's no widespread evidence that the Affordable
Care Act is hurting jobs.
One of John McCain's former economic advisors
admitted just this week -- and I'm quoting
here -- "I was expecting to see it.
I was looking for it," but "it's not there."
It's not there.
(Applause.)
The reason is reforming health care is going
to help the economy over the long term.
Not only will it help lower costs for businesses,
not only will it help families, it will free
up entrepreneurship in this country.
Because if you've got a great idea for your
own business but you've never tried it because
your spouse had a preexisting condition and
you didn't want to lose your employer-based
coverage, you've got the ability now to get
your own coverage.
That's security.
That's freedom.
So we're now only five days away from finishing
the job.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Five days away.
THE PRESIDENT: Five days.
(Applause.)
Starting on Tuesday, you can sign up.
But you don't have to sign up on Tuesday.
You've got six months to enroll in these new
plans.
You can go to the website; you can check it
out; you can see if what I'm saying is true.
(Laughter.)
You can sign up next week.
You can sign up next month.
You can sign up two months from now, three
months from now.
But you can sign up.
Tell your friends, tell your classmates, tell
your family members about the new health care
choices.
Talk to folks at your church, in your classroom.
You're going to a football game, basketball
game -- talk to them.
Tell them what the law means.
And over the next few months, state and local
leaders from across the country are going
to hold events to help get the word out.
Go out there and join them.
Secretary of Health and Human Services Kathleen
Sebelius is in Texas right now, working with
folks on the ground to make sure this law
works for Texas families.
All across the country, people are getting
ready.
All kinds of people are working hand-in-hand
because we're all in this together -- that's
when America is at its best.
That's what this country is all about.
But we need you to spread the word.
But you don't have to take my word for it.
If you talk to somebody who says, well, I
don't know, I was watching FOX News and they
said this was horrible -- (laughter) -- you
can say, you know what, don't take my word
for it, go on the website.
See for yourself what the prices are.
See for yourself what the choices are.
Then make up your own mind.
That's all I'm asking.
Make up your own mind.
I promise you, if you go on the website and
it turns out you're going to save $100, $200,
$300 a month on your insurance, or you'll
be able to buy insurance for the first time,
even if you didn't vote for me -- (laughter)
-- I'll bet you'll sign up for that health
care plan.
(Applause.)
So you don't need to listen to the politicians.
You don't need to listen to me.
Just go check it out for yourself.
Make up your own mind whether this works for
you.
Look, part of the reason I need your help
to make this law work is because there are
so many people out there working to make it
fail.
One of the biggest newspapers in the country
recently published an editorial I thought
was pretty good.
They said, the Republicans in Congress are
poisoning Obamacare, then trying to claim
it's sick.
(Laughter.)
That's exactly what's been happening.
I mean, they have tried to put up every conceivable
roadblock.
They cut funding for efforts to educate people
about what's in the law.
Some of them said if their constituents called
them, we won't even try to explain to them
what's in the law.
They actually opened up an investigation into
people who try to help churches and charities
understand how to help people sign up for
the law.
Some of the tea party's biggest donors -- some
of the wealthiest men in America -- are funding
a cynical ad campaign trying to convince young
people not to buy health care at all.
I mean, think about it.
These are billionaires several times over.
You know they've got good health care.
AUDIENCE: Right!
(Applause.)
THE PRESIDENT: But they are actually spending
money on television, trying to convince young
people that if you've got the choice between
getting affordable health care or going without
health care, you should choose not having
any health care.
Now, do you think if you get sick or you get
hurt, and you get stuck with a massive bill,
these same folks, they're going to help you
out?
AUDIENCE: No!
THE PRESIDENT: Are they going to pay for your
health care?
AUDIENCE: No!
THE PRESIDENT: It is interesting, though,
how over the last couple years, the Republican
Party has just spun itself up around this
issue.
And the fact is the Republicans' biggest fear
at this point is not that the Affordable Care
Act will fail.
What they're worried about is it's going to
succeed.
(Applause.)
I mean, think about it.
If it was as bad as they said it was going
to be, then they could just go ahead and let
it happen and then everybody would hate it
so much, and then everybody would vote to
repeal it, and that would be the end of it.
So what is it that they're so scared about?
AUDIENCE MEMBER: You!
(Laughter and applause.)
THE PRESIDENT: They have made such a big political
issue out of this, trying to scare everybody
with lies about "death panels" and "killing
granny" -- (laughter) -- right?
"Armageddon."
So if it actually works, they'll look pretty
bad.
If it actually works, that will mean that
everything they were saying really wasn't
true and they were just playing politics.
AUDIENCE: That's right!
THE PRESIDENT: Just the other day, one Republican
in Congress said we need to shut this thing
down before the marketplaces open and people
get to see that they'll be getting coverage
and getting these subsidies because -- and
I'm going to quote him here -- he said, "It's
going to prove almost impossible to undo Obamacare."
(Laughter.)
Right?
So in other words, we've got to shut this
thing down before people find out that they
like it.
(Laughter and applause.)
That's a strange argument.
Don't you think that's a strange argument?
AUDIENCE: Yes!
THE PRESIDENT: And the closer we get, the
more desperate they get.
I mean, over the last few weeks the rhetoric
has just been cranked up to a place I've never
seen before.
One congressman said that Obamacare is "the
most dangerous piece of legislation ever passed."
(Laughter.)
Ever.
In the history of America, this is the most
dangerous piece of legislation.
(Laughter.)
Creating a marketplace so people can buy group
insurance plans -- the most dangerous ever.
You had a state representative somewhere say
that it's "as destructive to personal and
individual liberty as the Fugitive Slave Act."
AUDIENCE: Booo --
THE PRESIDENT: Think about that.
Affordable health care is worse than a law
that let slave owners get their runaway slaves
back.
AUDIENCE: No!
THE PRESIDENT: I mean, these are quotes.
I'm not making this stuff up.
And here's one more that I've heard -- I like
this one -- we have to -- and I'm quoting
here -- "We have to repeal this failure before
it literally kills women, kills children,
kills senior citizens."
Now, I have to say -- that one was from six
months ago -- I just want to point out we
still have women -- (laughter) -- we still
have children, we still have senior citizens.
(Applause.)
All this would be funny if it wasn't so crazy.
And a lot of it is just hot air.
A lot of it is just politics.
I understand that.
But now the tea party Republicans have taken
it to a whole new level because they're threatening
either to shut down the government, or shut
down the entire economy by refusing to let
America pay its bills for the first time in
history -- unless I agree to gut a law that
will help millions of people.
AUDIENCE: Booo --
THE PRESIDENT: Think about this.
Shutting down the government just because
you don't like a law that was passed and found
constitutional, and because you don't like
the idea of giving people new access to affordable
health care -- what kind of idea is that?
Think about how that would impact Maryland.
This is an area where lots of people would
be badly hurt by a government shutdown.
A lot of people around here wake up and go
to serve their country every single day in
the federal government -- civilians who work
at military bases, analysts, scientists, janitors,
people who process new veterans' and survivors'
benefit claims.
They'd all have to stay home and not get paid.
And we all know it would badly damage the
economy.
Whatever effect Obamacare might have on the
economy is far less than even a few days of
government shutdown.
(Applause.)
I mean, even if you believe that Obamacare
somehow was going to hurt the economy, it
won't hurt the economy as bad as a government
shutdown.
And by the way, the evidence is that it's
not going to hurt the economy.
Obamacare is going to help the economy.
And it's going to help families and help businesses.
(Applause.)
As for not letting America pay its bills,
I have to say, no Congress before this one
has ever -- ever -- in history been irresponsible
enough to threaten default, to threaten an
economic shutdown, to suggest America not
pay its bills, just to try to blackmail a
President into giving them some concessions
on issues that have nothing to do with a budget.
I mean, this is the United States of America.
We're not a deadbeat nation.
We don't run out on our tab.
We don't not pay our note.
We are the world's bedrock economy, the world's
currency of choice.
The entire world looks to us to make sure
that the world economy is stable.
You don't mess with that.
(Applause.)
And that's why I will not negotiate on anything
when it comes to the full faith and credit
of the United States of America.
(Applause.)
We're not going to submit to this kind of
total irresponsibility.
Congress needs to pay our bills on time.
Congress needs to pass a budget on time.
Congress needs to put an end to governing
from crisis to crisis.
(Applause.)
Our focus as a country should be on creating
new jobs and growing our economy, and helping
young people learn, and restoring security
for hardworking, middle-class families.
(Applause.)
This is not about the fortunes of any one
party.
This is not about politics.
This is about the future of our country.
If Republicans do not like the law, they can
go through the regular channels and processes
to try to change it.
That's why we have elections.
So they can go through the normal processes
and procedures of a democracy, but you do
not threaten the full faith and credit of
the United States of America.
(Applause.)
And, meanwhile, we're going to keep implementing
the law.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: It's the law!
THE PRESIDENT: It's the law.
And like I said, there are going to be some
glitches along the way.
Every law has hiccups when it's first starting
off.
People forget, by the way, Medicare Part D
-- passed by my predecessor, George Bush,
passed by a Republican House of Representatives
-- the prescription drug bill passed into
law 10 years ago was even more unpopular than
the Affordable Care Act before it took into
effect.
Everybody was saying what a disaster it was
going to be.
The difference was Democrats worked with Republicans
to make it work even better.
(Applause.)
Steny remembers this.
Even though Democrats weren't happy that the
law wasn't paid for and was going to add hundreds
of billions of dollars to the deficit, and
we weren't negotiating a better deal with
the drug companies, everybody worked -- once
it was the law -- to try to make it work.
And today, about 90 percent of seniors like
their prescription drug coverage.
So we may not get that same level of cooperation
from Republicans right now.
But the good news is I believe eventually
they'll come around.
Because Medicare and Social Security faced
the same kind of criticism.
Before Medicare came into law, one Republican
warned that "one of these days, you and I
are going to spend our sunset years telling
our children and our children's children what
it once was like in America when men were
free."
That was Ronald Reagan.
And eventually, Ronald Reagan came around
to Medicare and thought it was pretty good,
and actually helped make it better.
So that's what's going to happen with the
Affordable Care Act.
And once it's working really well, I guarantee
you they will not call it Obamacare.
(Laughter and applause.)
Here is a prediction for you: A few years
from now, when people are using this to get
coverage and everybody is feeling pretty good
about all the choices and competition that
they've got, there are going to be a whole
bunch of folks who say, yes, I always thought
this provision was excellent.
(Laughter.)
I voted for that thing.
You watch.
(Laughter.)
It will not be called Obamacare.
But I'm always willing to work with anybody
from either party.
If you've got a serious idea for making the
Affordable Care Act better, or making our
broader health care system better, I'm happy
to work with you -- because that's what the
majority of the American people want.
They don't want posturing; they want governing.
They don't want politics; they want us to
work together to make the lives of ordinary
Americans a little bit better, a little bit
more secure.
(Applause.)
So, Maryland, I'm asking for your help.
I need your help.
(Applause.)
We may have some very well-funded opponents.
We may have some very talkative opponents.
But you're going to be the best, most credible
messengers to spread the word about this law
and all the benefits that the American people
stand to get and have earned.
So tell your friends, tell your family.
Get covered.
Get on that website.
Answer the questions of folks who don't know
what this is all about.
Point them to HealthCare.gov.
Teach them how to use the website.
Make sure they sign up.
Let's help our fellow Americans get covered.
(Applause.)
Then let's keep on working to rebuild the
middle class.
(Applause.)
Let's go and focus on creating more good-paying
jobs.
Let's build more ladders of opportunity for
everybody willing to work hard.
(Applause.)
Let's make sure the United States of America
keeps being a place where you can make it
if you try.
Thank you, everybody.
God bless you.
God bless the United States of America.
(Applause.)